if you're still eating your cereal with
low calorie almond milk and wondering
why you're starving you're doing it
wrong let me show you my favorite way to
bump up the flavor and the satiety
Factor by turning your non-dairy milk
into protein milk allmond milk down your
favorite protein
powder and a quick little this is
actually my favorite way to drink my
protein shake because I love a little
texture and crunch add your favorite
cereal I always do a mix and then any
other toppings you like it's basically
the lovech child of my two favorite Fast
breakfast cereal and protein shakes but
you get to eat it with a
[Music]
spoon mhm